Let me begin by introducing Joanne Lipman.
Um,
she has achieved great success and,
uh, in in the world of publishing,
a beginning as a reporter at the
Wall Street Journal on to being an
entrepreneur, uh, at the Wall
Street Journal in Cayenne,
Conde Nast and starting new editorial
properties within those organizations.
Uh,
she moved on to Ganette where she
ultimately became editor and chief of USA
Today and the chief content
officer, um, of, of,
of Guinot overall. So,
uh, also interestingly,
I had the tremendous pleasure of
getting to know Joanne over the last,
uh, year and a half, um, as we
were both members of the, uh,
of the Knight Commission on Trust Media
and democracy and where frankly at the
latter stages of completing that work,
and we'll publish a report sometime
in the next few months. Um,
which simply to me says that Joanna is
obviously not shy about taking on very
challenging questions. Uh, so you know,
what's the future of gender
equality in the workplace?
So what's the future of democracy
in the world of the Internet? Uh,
these are vexing problems.
Uh, and, um, they don't,
as we know, have necessarily
simple solutions. They have
constructive approaches,
but not necessarily simple solutions.
So we're here to talk about about Joanne's
book. By the way. There, there will be,
we do have several dozen copies available.
It is available also on kindle or
a book. That's what she said. Uh,
what men need to know and women need
to tell them about working together.
So let me just open up by
saying these are as we know,
very challenging times for our
society in, in many, many ways.
Um, these are also very challenging
times at Google. Um, as we well know,
and this last hour is
ample evidence of that, uh,
of the work we need to do,
um,
of the justifiable concerns that
many of us have about the urgency and
addressing these challenges.
And I hope today, uh,
and I get verklempt I hope
today an indication of our,
of our cultural commitment to
addressing them. Um, and again, it, it,
it's not over in the day. Uh, but I
do think there's symbolism, um, uh,
uh, to what happened today and, and
hopefully symbolism that has long value.
Uh, I might come back
to that later. So let's,
let's get into this joint and I,
I think your book,
and I'd strongly urge you to
read it. It's filled, uh, with,
with a tremendous amount of
information, um, examples, data,
uh, about the environment
we're in. Uh, and,
and Joanne does an excellent job of,
of illuminating those issues
of unconscious bias, um,
of how women feel in the workplace,
uh,
of how they're often perceived in the
workplace in ways that we know they should
not be perceived. Um, uh, and
as typical with these sessions,
I will,
after the first two or three or so,
open it up to all questions. Um, but I, I,
let me start off with a few and I want to,
your book makes her,
I think,
a really important point that
in addressing these issues,
it's how do we take
constructive approaches? Um,
how do we look more at the
do's and the don'ts? Um,
and I think we'll come back to that
several times in this conversation.
So let me just start off. Um,
you know, based on your work,
based on even what you might know
at a fairly high level about Google,
what, uh, what are the several
things that you would advise Google,
advise Googlers, uh, male or female in,
in guiding that evolution of a,
of a gender equal culture? Sure,
sure.
So first of all,
thank you guys for having me and thank
you for having me today of all days. So,
um, I was actually got here just
as the walkout was happening,
so I got to be a part of it and I,
and I was so energized by it.
And I also, uh, I've been following
Google, walked out, I'm on Twitter,
I'm watching this,
this cascade around the world,
which is amazing to see.
But what I loved being outside with all
you guys was how many men I saw and how
many hello male allies and,
and knowing Googlers like Richard.
Um, and that is actually why I
wrote, that's what she said. And,
and they're actually,
the reason that I wrote the book in
the first place is because I grew up,
you know,
my first two decades of my career,
I spent at the Wall Street Journal where
almost all of my colleagues were men.
My sources were man,
uh,
my mentors were all men and I had a
very good experience in a very male
dominated organization in a male
dominated industry. And, um,
and yet as I rose up the leadership ranks,
I started getting invited to more
and more on these women's leadership
conferences. And, um,
at a certain point I just became a
little bit frustrated because these
conversations were phenomenal.
Women's conversations with one another.
When we talk amongst ourselves,
we talk all the time about the issues we
face at work. And I don't mean just the,
the extremes of sexual abuse,
but the every day things of being
marginalized and overlooked,
interrupted, not taken it seriously, not
taken as seriously as the guy next to us.
And we talked about it all
the time with each other,
but men are not part of that
conversation. And, um, and so I actually,
the book grew out of a piece.
I ended up writing for the Wall
Street Journal called women at work,
a guide for men and in which I say,
and this is the point of the book,
women talking to each other.
It's a great conversation.
It's half a conversation and the
only way we're gonna get, you know,
that gets us to half the solution.
So the only way we solve this is for
us to all understand we need to work
together and bring men into the
conversation. So at a high level,
that's the most important thing.
That was amazing to see that today.
I also love seeing men here,
which is great. Um, and,
and I'd love being invited here.
Um,
I've been talking to a lot of male
dominated organizations. Um, you know, uh,
there are so many things that we can
talk about and I actually have a cheat
sheet in the back of the book on 10
things you can do right now to close the
gender gap.
But there,
it really breaks down into things that
individuals can do and things that
organizations can do.
And just to talk for a moment
organizationally because
I do think a lot of the
things that were on those five changes
actually mirror things that I recommend
in the book. Um, I, uh, things like, uh,
gender wage gap analysis
that is transparent I think
is very, very important.
There's a law now in the UK that just
went into effect that companies must
report their gender wage gap analysis.
And would anyone like to take a guess of
how many companies in the UK pay women
more than they pay men? Zero. Exactly.
Zero.
Well,
it's really important to know that
information so that you can act on that
information.
Um,
there are companies as well that
actually build it into compensation to
incentivize not just hiring,
but training,
recruitment and promotion and retaining
diverse talent, not just women,
but all diverse talent. I think
that that's very helpful. Um,
and then there are things
that we as individuals can do,
but the bottom line for organizations is
it really, it must come from leadership.
This is something I've learned.
I've been traveling around the country.
And I think the frustration that led to
the walkout today was a frustration in
that it's not that, you know, there's
thousands of women who have walked out.
It's not like thousands of women
have been sexually abused at work,
but I think it's,
it's the signal that that sends when
you have some bad behavior at the top,
the,
the signal that it sends to the rest of
the organization and through the culture
is that if you have that
kind of behavior at the top,
then what does that say about how we value
women in the rest of the organization?
And that translates into
things like respect,
which there's a huge respect gap between
men and women that has been documented
in the research.
Um,
and it's those kinds of things that I
think that we really individually we all
can address. As you point out,
often a role modeling is key.
Absolutely. And, and awareness is key. I
mean, I talk a lot about unconscious bias.
When you read the book,
there's actually a chapter focused
on Google and its efforts to combat
unconscious bias.
And I spent time with a fabulous
unconscious bias expert in your New York
office, Brian Welly, who's
absolutely great researcher. Um,
but I think that the question really yeah,
in unconscious bias is it's so important.
You have to be aware of it all the time.
And I know you guys have
unconscious bias trainings, um,
but a couple of hours of training
does not transform a culture.
And so there's so many things that,
um,
that we need to be aware of just in
everyday life. Um, unconscious bias,
I'm sure you all know what it is
because you've all been trained, right?
It's the biases we have that
are buried so deep inside of us.
We don't even realize they exist and we
all have them. Men, women, black, white,
no matter what.
We all have them
deeply about. Our tribes are in a
sense that sort of sense of tribalism.
It is. It is. And so we don't always,
we're not always aware of how that,
how that impacts us, but,
but just as a couple of,
for instances, um, you know, women,
it turns out women are interrupted
three times more frequently than men.
The Northwestern actually did a study of
the Supreme Court of the United States
and found that these females,
supreme court justices are interrupted
three times more frequently than male
Supreme Court justices. Um,
another thing that they'd probably,
every woman here has
experienced, um, is, uh,
that thing that happens when
you're in a room. Generally,
if women are in a minority in a group,
in a meeting,
which has certainly happened to me many
times, and most of you probably, um,
it is true, your voices aren't heard. Um,
there's this research shows that if
you make up 30% or less of a room, um,
the women's voices are there.
They're literally like the ear is
tuned to the male voices in the room.
So, um, how many women here,
I've had that experience, right?
Where you say something in a meeting
and it's like nobody heard it. Crickets,
right? And then two minutes later a guy
repeats exactly what you just said and
everybody throws at him. They're like,
Dave, great idea you had Dave. Right?
Well that I,
that's happened to me a million times
and I used to think it was just me,
but it turns out it is in the research
that is actually something that is very
common to almost all women.
Okay. You mentioned, um, training,
unconscious bias training.
One of the things that I was surprised
to learn from the book was the research
that tells us that diversity training
doesn't work and that it's in fact
counterproductive. Um, you know, it
felt counterintuitive to me, but,
but also as you went into it wise,
um,
and so I think it'd be great for you to
explain like, why is that the case? And,
and,
and more importantly,
what do you think that tells us about
how we guide our workforce force in,
in building a gender equal culture?
Yeah.
So there actually research a Harvard
professor by the name of Frank Dobbin did
this research where he looked at,
and this was at a traditional, um,
diversity training.
So he looked at 30 years of diversity
training at more than 800 companies.
And he found that for two groups,
for women as well as
for black men and women,
that not only did it not work,
it actually made things worse for
those two groups. In other words,
those companies, those two groups would
have fared better in those companies,
had there been no training at all.
And he dial delved into
the reasons for this.
And there were a variety of reasons.
Um,
but one of them was that,
um,
it was resentment on the
part of the primarily white
men who were subject to the
training.
So I went back and found some of these
traditional trainers and one of them
actually said to me, look, when we started
diversity training about 30 years ago,
um, it was in response
to lawsuits and he said,
and our process basically was beating
white guys over the head with a two by
four and trying to make them feel guilty.
And he sent out a big cry.
And even better, so
the, the, the, you know,
it had exactly the reverse of the intended
effect that actually has in gendered
and led to the rise of
unconscious bias training.
Because the idea with unconscious
bias training is we all have it.
We're not trying to make
you feel guilty about it.
We're just trying to help
you interrupt it. Um,
but I think the issue with
unconscious bias training you do,
you still do have people including a, you
had a situation here at Google as well.
You do have people who still feel
like they're getting beaten up. Um,
but I think the larger issue
really is simply unconscious bias.
Training is not in and of itself a fix.
It is a piece of a culture
and that culture really is
that that's what we really
need is a cultural overhaul. And that's,
that's not specific to Google. This is,
this is our corporate life in this country
really needs to have an overhaul in
how we interact with one another.
You can't help but think there's,
there's,
I mean there's something very deep in
that, I mean, you mentioned for instance,
just the dynamics of how we guide
irrespective of this issue of how we give
criticism to people saying performance
reviews in your k in one of the things
you mentioned in, and also in terms of
being too shy about giving harsh guidance.
But to me though, I think the
larger lesson is that is, um,
which I think we learned in all kinds
of ways in terms of parenting is like,
it's always so much better to give an
individual and guidance to how they can
succeed and assume they will succeed
rather than telling them about all the
things they've done wrong and assuming
they will continue to do it wrong.
Right. Yeah, I would totally
agree with that. I would add in,
there was some research that shows
us some of the biases that creep into
performance reviews. So,
um, one actually is, um,
and this, this stunned me actually,
I'm sorry, but for the in,
in writing the book I traveled
around the country and the,
and the world seeking are primarily men
in positions of authority who are trying
to close the gap. And the first question
because I wanted to learn from them,
you know,
what are the strategies,
like what are success stories and
strategies that we can all learn from.
But one of the, the first question
I would always ask them is,
tell me what perplexes or frustrates
you about the women who you work with.
And I was stunned by how
many of these men said,
I'm afraid she'll cry.
Now it is actually true that younger
women do cry biologically speaking more
than older men.
But the interesting thing is these
men were afraid that they would
unintentionally say something
to a subordinate female
and unintentionally hurt
her feelings. But here's the
thing, the research tells us,
and actually any woman in this room will
also tell us that when a woman does cry
at work,
it is not because her feelings are hurt,
it is because she's pissed off.
She's furious.
A woman crying at work is
actually treating much the
same thing as a man yelling
at work. But these executive men,
it has a serious consequence,
which is actually catalyst did this
survey of executive men and said,
what might stand in
the way of you, um, uh,
supporting gender equality at work and uh,
something like it was a
more than 70% of them,
I think it was 74% of them cited fear.
And part of the fear was,
you know, fear of loss of status,
particularly among other men.
But part of the fear was fear
of saying the wrong thing. And,
and what that led to and
other research has shown this,
is that these men who were in positions
of authority are afraid to give candid
feedback to women in the way
that they give it to men.
And what that results in is women
getting many more of these, um, um,
evaluations that talk about
their personality. Um,
and often have a personality critique.
You know,
she's abrasive or brash or
aggressive in a bad way.
Um,
versus men who tend to get
very constructive performance
oriented critiques.
And again, that's another
thing. It's very subtle,
but what that ends up doing is giving
men more of the information they need to
succeed and the women aren't getting it.
You're getting too many insights about
unconscious bias into our cultural biases,
um, into stereotypical
models of male behavior,
stereotypical models of societal
behavior for that matter.
And like you mentioned in the
book that you wear high heels, uh,
to in a sense puts yourself
closure on more equal footing,
which interestingly resonated
with me and that I, uh,
I'm not a particularly tall guy.
I've,
I've raised a lot of money from
venture capital firms and the,
the end of that process is always you
presenting to the full partnership.
But there Monday meeting and these
are talk about macho ego driven rooms.
It's like way up there and
the ethos and VC firms is,
it's the idea is one thing,
but it's all the CEO, um,
in, in a pretty extreme way. And when
I would go into those presentations,
I would literally sort of puff myself up.
I would stand several inches taller.
I would get closer to people,
I'd use my arms, I'd speak
more loudly. Um, you know,
to kind of present myself in the
way they were expecting to see me.
Um, and I think there are obvious
techniques that work for all,
but I couldn't help in thinking about
that saying, in fact, my wife, by the way,
she jokes, she's like, you're the only
five, nine guy who thinks he's six, two,
um, but we're a six PC.
But does that, is that,
are we playing into patriarchal
models with that? I mean,
to what extent is it about patriarchal
models or is it about societal models and
how does that matter to
what we're talking about?
Yeah. Look, I mean we,
it would be great for us to be able to
wipe out all of these kinds of concerns.
Like, like that right. It would
be terrific. But until then,
there are strategies and,
and what you experienced is what women
experience every day and often many times
a day. So, um, so I actually
in the, in the research,
so I do wear high heels everyday and I
always thought it was because I worked
around men and I wanted to have
a physically larger presence.
But it turns out that taller women
earn 8% more than shorter women.
Women who wear makeup earn
more than those who do not.
Women who are thin out earn those who
are heavy and people generally men and
women who were better looking
for more and taller. Right?
Hi, is it fast? Yeah. Yup.
It is an actual, it's a thing. It's
a real thing. Um, but for women,
grooming actually counts much more.
And there was this great calculation.
Debora spar,
who was the president of Barnard,
calculated that over the
course of her career,
a professional woman will spend a total
of five full years longer than her male
spouse or a colleague getting
ready for work. Like the hair,
the makeup, the, you know,
just maintenance. And we
talked down. Fascinating.
But again, it's, it's the, the,
the world that we live in and, and,
and including Google,
I mean the,
the work world that we live
in was created by men for men.
And so women are in a,
in a sense trying everyday there's a
thousand things we do, some conscious,
some unconscious to try and fit
into the world created by men.
And a huge reason why I wrote, that's
what she said was to make men aware.
I actually gear the book toward men even
though, I mean it's for women as well,
obviously.
But I really want to bring men in and
to understand what some of these issues
are just so that they have an
awareness of it. Because you know,
women are leaning in so
far we're falling over. Um,
but the man who I spoke to were awesome
and these are guys who realize that they
have to reach out as well. It's not
just a one sided thing. And I think,
I do think that there's been a little bit
of a too much of an onus put on women,
particularly these past few
years, that it's all on us, ran a,
we have to demand to be paid what we're
worth. We have to go out there and, and,
and, and, um, you know, fix the
patriarchy. Ah, but in fact,
it actually, this is a two sided
equation and we need the men to,
to recognize that as well and join us.
I'm going to move to the audience.
Um, there's a question on the dory,
um, that I think relates to what
we're talking about here. Uh,
this person says,
you've talked about differences in the
ways that women and men typically present
their thoughts, suggestions
versus declarations. Uh,
not all men and women
present in the typical way.
How much of the lack of respect for
those approaches do you tribute to the
approach itself? The technique
versus speakers? Gender?
Yeah, that's a great question. And the
first thing I would say is that, so,
so it is documented that women do use
more hedging language than men do.
And that would be things like,
I hate to bother you, but,
and this might be a
stupid question, but, um,
we use more up speak like when we ask a
question when we made a statement, um,
and we apologize all the time
and we are not sorry. Uh,
but we will use that verbal tick and
we're highly aware of these verbal ticks
and we try like tracing to,
to counteract them.
But the other thing I will say is I've
heard from so many readers if that's what
she said, who are, because all of
this applies not just to women,
but to pretty much anyone who is
in an underrepresented group. Um,
and so much of the research I site
also deals not just with women but with
underrepresented groups.
And one of the groups of
people have readers who that
I have heard a lot from is
introverted men who say,
all of these behaviors
are my behaviors as well,
and I suffer from the same consequences.
So I think it's, it's relevant,
highly relevant.
And,
and that's why it's so important to be
aware of it because it is right now.
It isn't the norm of behavior and women
have spent many years trying to fit that
norm. And what we need to do
is have men be aware and women,
all of us kind of be aware of these
different communication styles and just be
more,
yeah,
sensitive to,
I want to be specific to it and I'm
going to take the next question from the
room so you get your thoughts together.
Um,
couple of things there.
You mentioned in the book about
how important mentoring is. A,
you mentioned how often
senior men are uncomfortable,
concerned about perceptions
in mentoring younger women,
which frankly had kind of
thing as a cop out. Um,
I think if we can as professionals figure
out how to manage that dynamic, then,
you know, probably you shouldn't
be doing what you're doing.
But just put that aside. Um,
in, in my own experience,
I particularly in Mike more
advanced stage as it were,
meaning I'm old. Um, um, I, I do enjoy, I,
one of my great pleasure that Google
trying to coach people. I say try.
I don't know how good
at it. I am, but, but,
but I've also sense that in this
engineering centric culture,
um,
uh,
it's not just about men and women and
it's not just about women in this regard.
Um, that, uh, there are many folks
here who are, who are introverted,
not self assertive. Um, um,
but the question I have for you is,
is
I mean today and I try to coach women in
pretty much the same way as that coach
men.
Um,
but are there different approaches that
one should take place or is it just
about different sensitivities?
So first of all,
100% agree with you about being a cop out.
There's on, there are men out there who
say up like, yeah, no, me too. I can't,
I'm never going to talk to a
woman. I can't mentor a woman. Um,
and that's just bullshit. Sorry,
I have no patience for that.
That's generally men who
aren't mentoring women anyway.
But there are many,
many different ways to mentor.
And I think that the big
differences and that we are,
we know from the research that women tend
to have mentors who give them advice.
Men tend to have what are known as
sponsors who can get them promotions.
And so actually the,
that Harvard Research I mentioned earlier
thank dob and when he was looking at
what are solutions that work versus
the old fashioned diversity training,
one of them was formal
mentorship programs. And the,
the idea with a formal
mentorship program is,
it's not that I am mentoring
Susan because she's a woman.
It is because I am mentoring whoever
it is because they are in my field.
And very often what ends up happening
is senior women end up being paired with
or, or sought out by other women. Um,
but they're not in the same
field. They can't help. Right.
And it's, it's, you know,
it's not gender mentoring
gender. It is, you want,
you want to be mentored by somebody
who can actually help you advance.
And I think that's the, that's
the big, big difference.
Is there a question in
the room I think is this,
um,
I think what you're saying
is so interesting because
when I look back over the
course of my career,
no one has done more for me in
my career than white men, right?
And I work with so many women and
I offered my mentorship to them and
sponsorship and in certain cases as well.
And when I often hear is,
is like there's just not enough
females in leadership positions.
So I just don't have any mentors. I
don't have any sponsors. And you know,
my thought there is,
is like it doesn't have to be a woman
like look to these men because they are in
the positions of power and
they will do a lot for you.
And I wonder if it's sort of, there's
an oversaturation of just like these,
these men don't have enough time to, is,
there's few of them I would say, who are,
um, as connected to sort of women in
the way that the women want them to be.
And I'm wondering, you know, how do we,
what can we do to enable more men to
understand how women need to be mentored
and what they expect from sponsorships?
Because so much of it comes back to
your point around women in a lot of
underrepresented groups actually don't
get the critical skill based feedback
that they need. They're not
getting skill-based mentorship.
And that continues the vicious cycle of
people not sort of understanding what
really needs to happen because there's
a fear of hurting feelings or that
sensitivity.
So it's that,
yes, you made a great point. And, and um,
and that it actually there what you're
talking about is why this department
professor said these formal programs are
actually more effective. And in fact, um,
there are a couple of organizations
that I cite in the book that,
that put into effect
these formal programs.
And they found that it helped
with retention and promotion,
not just of the people
who are being mentored,
but it helped with retention of the
people who were doing the mentoring,
which is also really interesting.
Um, but yes, I think we have to,
we have to think about that. Skills
based mentoring. We have a tendency,
all of us as humans to gravitate toward
people who remind us of ourselves.
And that has been a huge issue. Um,
one of the, one of the solutions,
one of the things that my recommendations,
and that's what she said, um,
is to have a Rooney rule.
So you guys know what the Rooney rule is.
If it's in football,
if you have an opening,
you need to have a diverse slate
of candidates to choose from.
But what I'm recommending
and what I learned from the
men who I interviewed was,
that's not enough.
You actually need to have a diversity of
people who are doing the interviewing.
And that goes to whether they're
thinking about looking at somebody to be
promoted or filling an opening,
you need a diverse slate of people because
if you've got a bunch of white guys
who are evaluating a
diverse group of people,
you still do not get an optimal result.
And,
and the other thing I will say is so
many companies that I visit with say, oh,
we really want women in our senior ranks,
but we can't find any.
And to them I say, and to Google,
I say, look, in your junior ranks,
look what are you, what's
happening there? Right? What?
Look at who are the people who are
coming in? Look at every single level,
especially in those low, lower
levels, leading to middle management.
Look at every level and see who are
you promoting it, who are you not,
who are you losing and who are you not
because there's leakage in there and
there's people who are being passed
over who, um, who should not be.
Um, and I think that that, and
it doesn't, if you do that,
it's not going to take you that long
until you've grown your own leaders. Um,
I actually, I had a, um, so
I spoke at a consulting big,
one of the big consulting firms and I
had dinner afterward with a table of 10
senior women at this consulting firm.
And they went around the table and all
of them had been recruited by other major
consulting firms and because they
were already at a senior level,
and that's the problem.
If we're just shuffling the
same too few women at the top,
we are not going to get anywhere.
Right. I spoke to a bank that, um,
that before I,
when I did a little bit of research and
I found that they had made a commitment
to gender equality in 1982 I'm
speaking to her room. I said,
most of you guys here
were not born in 1982.
You had plenty of time to get
yourself to gender equality,
but they're losing the women on the way
up and they're not growing their own
leaders.
And I think that is so essential.
Not enough companies are focused on that.
Yeah. I think that's so true. By
the way, one of the things I think,
again, I'm trying to facilitate
mentoring and mentoring programs.
MMM.
One thing I, I, I feel it also important
to recognize is, is to encourage people,
oh,
um,
encourage people to ask
someone for mentoring. Um, uh,
you know, not be shy about that.
I mean, when you think about it,
it's actually kind of a nice ego
inflating thing if come on says it says,
can you help me?
You know more than I do.
You've been around the track a few
more times. Um, that, uh, it's, it's,
that's a, that's a very simple path
if you can be comfortable doing that.
So that's the key is if you
can be comfortable. I mean gas,
I agree that's a great idea.
But I think again,
it puts the onus on the person
with less power and we've,
we put too much onus already
on the people with less power.
We need to go more on the
people with power. And in fact,
while I was writing the book and I was,
I can add and it actually changed the
way I manage and I started realizing that
when we had openings, and especially
like with internal openings,
I'd have all these guys who
would put their hands up for it,
but there would be women or
or minority Pete, you know,
people of color who were not
putting their hands up, who should,
would have been very qualified in the
pool. So I took it on myself to say,
cause I was in the middle of this
research, I was like, wait a second.
So I would like actually
going in the newsroom and,
and talk to people and bring
them into my office and say, Hey,
I see you didn't put your hand up.
You should know that you were
qualified to be in this pool.
Doesn't mean that you would get the job.
And I'm not telling you you have to put
your hat in, but you should know that.
And if you're not interested,
let's talk about what you might
be interested in down the line.
And I realized belatedly,
I think that it was really my
responsibility as a leader to go out and,
and make sure that these people who have
talent are given these opportunities
and it shouldn't always be on their head.
Excellent point.
I'm going to move to our verge. Oh, we
have a [inaudible] virtual audience.
Thank you.
Um,
sometimes at an individual level we will
see managers behaving in ways that are
not as agregious as firing,
but still are kind of leading
outcomes that decreased diversity.
And
I have thought about speaking up many
a time and I've had male mentors for me
who cared about me personally,
who advised me not to speak up,
that it would hurt my career.
And one of the few times
that I did choose to do that,
suddenly I, I did feel some,
some pretty bad consequences.
So what is your advice to people who
are seeing things that are in the gray
area? Yes. Should they actually,
what kinds of actions are
actually productive? Cause
I haven't figured it out.
Yeah. I, this is where allyship
is so important. I mean,
what you're talking about is so
common in all organizations. Um,
and this is, I talk a lot about
different kinds of allies,
women with women or with men. Um, but
that's what's so important. I mean,
I think one of the issues particularly
that women face is particularly if this
behavior is directed at them
and, and, and maybe it does,
it doesn't rise to the level of firing,
but it is demeaning perhaps
or, or, or dismissive.
Um, and the women feel like, Ugh, I got
to figure out how to deal with this.
And that's where allies come in. Um, in,
in the case that you're talking about,
I would have hoped that the
mentors would have, would have,
they would have stepped up and intervened.
And that's,
that's the kind of behavior that we
want to encourage that kind of allyship.
And I,
and I tell people that your ally
can be somebody at your level.
It can be somebody in
a different department.
I have found in different organizations,
sometimes I have been approached by
somebody who doesn't report to me,
who was not in my department to
tell me about some sort of, um,
behavioral issues with the manager.
And it's really important to do that.
And one of the reasons it's important
is because I can say almost every time,
maybe every time that has ever happened
to me where I'd been approached about
with somebody says,
I don't want to bring it up to my boss.
But almost always the person they're
talking about has a history of bad
behavior.
And they,
so you need to surface that so that
the person can be either talk to
disciplined, dismissed, whatever,
whatever the correct course of action is.
Too often we, we stay quiet. And that's
why it's important to have that ally.
And I'm sure Richard, you've probably
had this situation to people, you know,
you're, you're like, you're
one of the good guys, right?
So I can imagine somebody coming
to you and confiding in you,
but I would imagine you wouldn't tell
them to be quiet. You would try and,
no, I mean, and I, you know,
I can't say it was like no,
always with the perfect techniques are,
but you have so many of
those circumstances. I mean,
it's understandable that,
that,
that the individual construct confronting
the manager is not likely to achieve
the best result in both ways for that
matter and ended up with a consequence you
don't like, which is why you, you'd like,
do you think that that organizations would
have people and mechanisms to address
that cause in that context? Um, you know,
depending on the circumstance, yeah,
there are ways to address that and there
a drays to west or address that without
the individual being in a sense brought
into the equation. Right, right. Yeah.
I can give it bad
behavior. It, I, you know,
I don't have to declare who
complained, uh, there, you know,
there are lots of clever ways to
deal with that. I think if you, if,
if you try,
and actually two quick ones because I'm,
these both worked in real
life. So one was, uh,
I was talking to a senior executive,
I was out on book tour and
the senior executive, a big
consumer products company,
um,
came up to me to that to tell me,
he said he had a team senior team and he
said there was a woman on his team and
she was like a real ball buster. She was
great. Like he didn't worry about her,
but she came to him privately and said,
Hey,
have you noticed that when
we are in our meetings,
there's this particular guy who every
time I opened my mouth he shuts me down or
cuts me off or takes credit for my idea.
And this boss said,
actually I had not noticed, but once I did
we need, he said, we made a secret pact.
And the secret pact was I was going to
be on the lookout for that behavior.
And every time I saw it I was
going to intervene and back her up.
And he wouldn't have known
had she not mentioned that.
And one other example in which
happened with me was somebody not in my
department came to me at an
organization. And, and said,
I don't want to complain to my own boss,
but there's a particular guy who is,
is dismissive. And I know another
woman who quit because the way he,
they didn't like the way you treated,
but it's not like he's hitting
on us or anything like that.
It's just dismissive beer.
So I actually went to, um,
a friend in HR and the friend said,
I'm so glad you came to me because
that particular guy has a record.
I didn't know that. Um, but
that's why it's so important.
Like they needed this information,
they needed to know this information so
that they could take the proper action.
So I mean, in some cases, what I've
done at night, you know, again,
it's so much depends on the circumstance
is in providing that feedback to the
individual as you sort of like
multiply it, right. Instead of like,
I'm getting feedback. Yeah. Yes.
And it's not necessarily singular
and getting feedback. Yep.
Obviously that doesn't work in all
circumstances and I get that. I don't, I,
I think one of the last ones
are just like, you know,
Richard Di you use a lot of
foul language. Uh, you know,
some people aren't comfortable with that
and I see some people I work laughing.
I haven't yet mastered this solution
to that, but I'm trying over here.
Hi. Um, so I have a question, um,
about when working towards
closing the gender gap,
how do we make sure that people that
don't identify as gender binary fall
through the cracks?
That's a great question. The,
the, and I make a real effort in,
that's what she said to look at research.
That is it.
The book itself is gender,
but I make a real effort to
look at underrepresented groups.
And I think what you're
talking about people there,
you're talking about fall into the
category of underrepresented groups. And,
and that did,
if you're talking about people
who are not gender binary, um,
people who are people who fall into
other, you know, religious minority,
I mean there are,
there are,
there are a lot of people
who unfortunately experienced
these same issues and I
think a lot of the same strategies hold
and I was very cognizant of that as I
put together the cheat sheet. I'm at
the end of the book for, you know,
recommendations and things we can do.
And I'm actually working as we speak on
updating the book for paperback to look
separately for individuals steps.
We can take an organization's steps
that organizations should be taking.
Thank you. Um, I'm going to go
to our virtual audience. Um,
how much of a company's actions are
attributed to it being self serving?
A quote I've heard is that human
resources will help someone as long as it
doesn't go against the
interest of the company.
Yeah.
So I think that your allies,
when I'm talking about
allyship is not necessarily HR.
Hr does have a role in
protecting the company. Um,
I what I,
what I strongly feel is the best
way to overhaul the culture.
And it really does have to
start with the leadership.
The leadership has to not just talk the
talk, but they have to walk the walk.
They have to model the behavior and
um, and they have to sh, you know,
and I also think that, um, um,
incentives need to be modeled as well
to incentivize the right kinds of
behaviors. We all react according to
incentives and if our incentives, um,
have nothing to do with, it's kind of the,
yeah, the, the inclusion and diversity,
then we're not going
to pay attention to it.
And I've met some amazing Dni
professionals in my travels,
but they alone cannot change a culture.
Really only the leadership can do that.
I'm to,
I'm going to probe a little bit more to
that because it's obviously it's, it's,
it's actually, it's absolutely true that
companies operate out of self interest.
I mean, they should, it's the nature
of, uh, of its existence, uh, you know,
rewarding at shareholders, so on
and so forth. To me, the, the, the,
the objective indeed the opportunity is
how do you guide that to be more self
enlightened, uh, or uh, in enlightened
self interest is what I'm trying to say.
And you talk a lot in the
book about examples of how
companies are stronger when
they have a gender diversity,
how they design better products
when they have gender diversity.
So to me that's the
enlightened self interest. Yup.
How do you build a talented workforce?
Absolutely. Absolutely. So every
piece of research shows you,
and you've probably heard some of this,
that and gender balanced leadership
and the gender balanced organization is
actually more successful
by every financial measure.
And that goes for your board of directors.
You know,
companies that have the most women on
boards are more financially successful
than those with the least companies with
gender balanced leadership outperform
those without, by a factor of, you know,
like a double digit percentage
in terms of return on equity.
But also workgroups,
gender balanced work groups
are better at problem solving.
They're more creative when
it comes to solutions.
There was even this research that showed
that they are more accurate in solving
a murder. Um, there was this
research where they had to,
they had is an all male,
all female and mixed gender group and
they gave them a real life murder case to
solve.
And um,
both single sex groups had so much fun
with this exercise and they agreed very
quickly on who the culprit was and they
were very confident of the results.
The mixed gender group took longer.
It was less fun.
There was more back and forth.
They were less confident that the result.
But guess who was right? They
were right. They were right.
Because you need that input from a
variety of perspectives to really come to
your ultimate best solution.
So another question
from the audience.
While Google strives for diversity,
it can be a challenge.
When Rankin file managers do not value
diversity of opinions or recognize
employees who approach problems
from a different perspective,
how can that be managed?
Now,
actually this kind of hits home with me
because this is something where I feel I
often have to kind of remind myself to um,
in gender multiple opinions and frankly
breakthrough my own thinking. I mean,
I think there's is interesting
psychological element
that as any of us become
more confident in what we do,
um,
more confident in whether it's
leadership skills or knowledge,
you also inherently kind of start to
close your mind a little bit and it takes
effort to break through. I don't
feel like I've mastered that at all.
Yeah, I think that that is a
great point. And they, the, um,
that's part of the diversity that that's
part of the awareness factor. I mean,
being aware that you tend
to like, you know, I,
I've been in organizations where they say,
oh, the boss really likes brassy women.
Well, what if you're a quiet woman?
Right? Uh, you know, the, the, you,
you really have to check yourself.
And again, I do think that, um,
this is an issue that we see a lot of
in companies where you have sort of
enlightened leadership, particularly in
big companies, enlightened leadership.
But then you hear, you know
what, it's not trickling down.
I have a manager who doesn't value
what the company is valuing in terms of
diversity of opinion,
diversity of, of approach.
And I do think, again, that is why
it's so that's why I think our, our,
we have these intractable cultural,
um,
which is what leads to things like
today where we had thousands of people,
um, on the walkout in the walkout. Um,
but ultimately sometimes that's what
you need to move the needle to actually
affect change.
At the beginning of the talk,
you mentioned that women on the leadership
trainings and conversations can be so
valuable for that audience.
You also mentioned the statistic about um,
women getting interrupted in mixed
company and also diversity training
backfiring.
So I wonder how do you recommend that we
bridge those divides besides just sort
of waiting for male allies to
self identify and proactively
approached the group
in order to learn more about
the women's perspective?
Right.
So I actually advise women's Erg,
employee resource groups to invite men.
You don't have to invite them all the
time. But there is a great example of a,
of a firm, um, where, um, uh,
I heard that was a very male dominated
company and they had a women's meeting.
It's not,
it's not company as big as Google.
So they had all women's meeting for all
of their North America operations and
they decided we're going to
have just a women's meeting.
And then the few senior women said, you
know what, for a portion of this meeting,
we're each going to invite a senior man.
And it turned out that those invitations
were so coveted that all the senior men
were like lobbying to get invited
and like, did you get invited? Right.
It was like a big deal.
And the beauty of that was
that these senior men came,
they wouldn't have thought
of volunteering themselves,
but when they were invited in to hear
this conversation, they were able to,
first of all, they were able to hear
what's going on with the women. And,
but secondly,
and I think this is just as important,
they were able to create these bonds
and relationships with the women in the
firm and they were exposed to the
junior women in the firm as well,
who they normally would not have
really interacted with. So that means,
and this is what they found, that,
um, when it comes time for, you know,
big assignments for the,
the, the star assignments,
when it comes time for promotions, these
younger women are now, they're known,
they're top of mind. And it actually helps
with, um, bringing them all together.
So, so I do think that there we have
to kind of, we, we have to bring in,
in both sides here.
And when I go and talk to women's groups,
I always ask them to invite some man. I'm,
I'm speaking tomorrow at, um, there's, uh,
a women's power summit in
Hollywood. So I'm going to La, um,
to talk at this meeting,
but,
but I am in the one session where it's
about men and we'll be talking with men
and men are invited into the group because
I feel really strongly like that's,
uh, that, that that's where we need to
go. And the men are excited to be there.
Boom. You, you spent so much time on
this but could get ton of research.
Um, what surprised you? What, what,
what challenged your own
assumptions and conclusions?
So I, you know, a lot, but
I would say one of the,
probably one of the top issues that I
found as I was doing the research and
there's about 50 pages of
research notes in the back. Um,
as I was diving into the research, I came
across so many of these issues that I,
my entire life have
thought they were just me.
I thought it was my problem and just me.
And I was stunned to find there is that
it is not just me that is common to
women and it's common to people in
underrepresented groups. And, um,
so I think that was probably
the biggest surprise. Um,
and then the other part of it on the plus
side was it really did change the way
I behave as a manager,
both in terms of things like being
really focused on the people who are not
raising their hands, um, for a job. Um,
and also being really focused on who is
in the conversation when you're talking
about who should get a promotion
or who should get a bonus, right.
Understanding that we need
that diversity of opinion
being nor the questions on the door here.
How was,
how was the experience with the book
impacted you in the sense of the next
chapter of your own career? I
mean, you know, you, you, you,
you achieved great
professional success and we,
the organization's leadership positions.
This is a very different role
that you're in. Uh, you know,
so where do you see this taking
you professionally? Personally?
Yeah, it's been fascinating.
So since the book came out,
I've actually been speaking, I've
been kind of nonstop, I'm talking,
speaking weird meeting when organizations
and what happened was I started the
book three years ago, so
as long before me too, um,
and then me to happened and I doubled the,
on the plus side,
there is a growing realization
among organizations
including very male dominated
organizations like this one that we
haven't done enough and that there are
things that we have tolerated
that we shouldn't be tolerating.
And there is a lot of soul searching about
how do we, what do we do about it? So,
um, I've been, I've, I've been, um,
unexpectedly I expected I would write the
book and go on book tour for two weeks
as one does with a book and instead it's
just been sort of endlessly rolling.
Um,
because there's a lot of interest among
these organizations in trying to crack
the nut of where do we go next
and how do we solve this issue.
I will also tell you,
I have some frustrations in that.
It's been a year since me too,
since party Weinstein. Um,
and, um, there's been a lot
of talk, which is great.
There has not been enough action.
And again, I come back to the,
the, um, the walkout today,
which I've found so inspiring.
But what the walkout is doing is,
is it is a microcosm,
macrocosm of what I am
seeing around the country.
As I talk to companies in other industries
who are saying exactly what you guys
are saying, which is okay,
we hear you, that you're,
you're, you're saying the right
things, but we need to see action.
We need to see movement.
And that is not, um,
that is not unique to Google that I
am seeing that all over the country.
And in fact, um, globally as well. I've
been traveling internationally as well,
talking about the same issues and
seeing the same, the same conversation.
I do hope that,
you know,
you're thinking and expressions on this.
Um, it can help move that toward further.
Obviously these aren't,
this is not likely to be a short battle.
Um, so I so appreciate what you've
done, what you've shared. I mean,
as I said at the beginning,
I think these are just
extraordinary challenging times,
divisive times in so many dimensions
in our society and, and, uh, you know,
fart gender equality, the
situation politics. Uh, you know,
I still believe that the only way
we can address divisions is to,
is to find way to build bridges,
is to find way to talk across the divides,
find the right language, the
right solutions, the right
constructive approaches.
Um, you know, this has been an interesting
and challenging time at Google.
I've worked here for nearly 10 years
and I've, I've always believed that.
I do believe that it's a very
different company than most. Um,
it's a company that cares about
principles, that cares about its culture,
which doesn't mean it's perfect. Uh,
it's not in fact, I won't ever be,
and I think we act always assume
that our culture is not perfect. Um,
but I do think our only way forward is to,
is to engage,
to challenge each other's perspectives,
uh,
challenge each other productively,
constructively,
give them paths to success. Um, uh,
rather than just assume failure.
There are also some things,
and I know we're running out of time,
but there are also some things that
are very, um, specific to technology.
Um, so I will just like on just two
quick ones, what, you know, one is, um,
just in terms of, um, algorithms
and who, who's doing the coding,
um, whose code is accepted.
Uh, you probably know this,
but there's been some
blind blind taste tests.
So there was one done with get hub,
which has open source coding. Um,
and when coding was submitted anonymously,
women's code was accepted
more often than men's code.
So you could conclude that
women are better coders. Um,
but when names were attached to the code,
men's code was accepted at a
greater rate than women's code. Uh,
there was an engineer at Facebook who
did a similar experiment who clay and
Facebook disputes this, but
this engineer claimed that, um,
a code written by females at Facebook
was 35% less likely to be accepted than
code written by men.
And then,
then the other piece that that works
into is your algorithm. So when I,
when I go out on the road,
I have like a little PowerPoint that
when I talk about unconscious bias,
I show just Google image
searches for various things that,
that show partly our unconscious
bias. Um, as a, as a,
as a, you know, one example is
while I was writing the book, um,
I just did a search for CEO and image
search and it was all men except for one
woman.
And the one woman was CEO Barbie.
And that is a,
that reflects our own unconscious bias,
but it also is spit out
to us by an algorithm.
And the algorithms are largely
written by men. So, you know,
we have these very ingrained,
not intentional,
but sort of ingrained issues that
I think also are specific to tech.
And then one other that I would
mention is just simply, um,
in working on the book,
I spent time here and I spent time in
the Chelsea office in New York. Um,
and I loved it and I had a great time,
but I come from a male dominated world.
Um, but I noticed that, you know, to,
to, to go to the cafe in New York,
you pass the Lego Room, you pass the
game room, you know, you're, and I,
and I at the end,
after spending time and hearing about
all the great things you're doing to try
and get to gender balance,
I just spoke to a group of women
in the New York office and as it,
just as we're walking through that office,
I said,
I see the guys in the game room. I said,
do you guys ever go to the game room?
And they're like, are you kidding?
We want to be taken seriously.
We would never do that. And, and
it's just these little things.
And it wasn't like they were
complaining about it, but,
but it's a very gendered environment.
And it just made me wonder
because it really was decorated.
I had the sense of Deja
Vu and I swear to God,
I finally realized that the Google office
was decorated like the bedroom of my
10 year old son. And, and
it made me wonder like,
what would happen if the Google office
were decorated like a stereotypical 10
year old daughter with purple and pink
and fluffy things and glittery guns,
right?
Like,
how would the men feel if that's the
environment they worked in every day?
So there's these, these, uh, you know,
it's not intentional at all, but it does,
it itch.
It sort of has an impact on the culture
at large and how women feel and how
comfortable they feel in the culture.
Again, thank you. Usually
for what you've done,
for all the work you've done
and for sharing that with
us today and, and, uh, uh,
hope we might have a conversation a
year from now, two years from now,
three years from now, and we might
see progress having been made.
Fantastic. Well, thank you
for having me. Thank you guys.